"
FOX NEWS ALERT, IN A STUNNING
DEVELOPMENT, BILL COSBY IS A
FREE MAN, THE DISGRACED
ENTERTAINER APPEARING WITH HIS
LEGAL TEAM OUTSIDE HIS HOUSE
JUST MOMENTS AGO.
>> MR. COSBY HAS ALWAYS USED HIS
CELEBRITY, HIS NAME AND LIKENESS
TO UPLIFT WOMEN.
HOW COULD A MAN WHO WAS BEING
WATCHED BY THE FBI EVERY DAY BE
RAPING AND DRUGGING WOMEN IN THE
'60s END '70s?
TODAY IN A SENSE CAME TO
MR. COSBY.
>> WE KNOW HE NEVER SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PROSECUTED, THEY PULLED THE
RUG OUT FROM UNDERNEATH HIM
BECAUSE OF POLITICS, THE COURT
OF PUBLIC OPINION AND THAT IS
NOT HOW OUR SYSTEM SHOULD
OPERATE.
>> Jesse: THE ACTOR ONCE KNOWN
AS AMERICA'S DAD RETURNING HOME
AFTER BEING LET OUT OF PRISON ON
A TECHNICALITY, THE PENNSYLVANIA
SUPREME COURT OVERTURNING HIS
2015 SEXUAL ASSAULT CONVICTION.
THE COURT RULED THAT A
NONPROSECUTION AGREEMENT WITH
THE PREVIOUS PROSECUTOR SHOULD
HAVE PREVENTED COSBY FROM BEING
CHARGED IN THAT CASE.
THE JURY FOUND COSBY GUILTY OF
DRUGGING AND RAPING AT TEMPLE
UNIVERSITY SPORTS ADMINISTRATOR
AT HIS HOUSE IN 2004, THE FIRST
PERSON TO FALL IN THE #MeToo
MOVEMENT AFTER DOZENS OF WOMEN
CLAIMS THAT HE DRUGGED AND
MOLESTED THEM BUT NOW THE
83-YEAR-OLD IS NOW FREE MAN.
DANA, WE HEARD FROM THE COSBY
TEAM OUT THERE IN THE DRIVEWAY
IN PENNSYLVANIA.
A KIND OF MAKING COSBY OUT TO BE
THE LEADER OF THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT IF YOU TAKE THEM AT
THEIR WORD.
>> Dana: I UNDERSTAND WINNING
A CASE, YOU FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT.
THIS CAN HAPPEN, I THINK THAT
FOR THE WOMAN WHO CAME FORWARD
WHO TESTIFIED, IT'S A SAD DAY
FOR THEM, I THINK IT CAME OUT OF
THE BLUE.
I WASN'T EXPECTING THIS NEWS, IT
WAS WORKING ITS WAY THROUGH THE
SYSTEM BUT YOU DON'T REALLY
EXPECT A TECHNICALITY LIKE THIS
TO OVERTURN A JURY TRIAL BUT
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED AND HE IS A
FREE MAN.
HE IS HOME, I THINK FOR TWO
YEARS OF A 10-YEAR SENTENCE PAID
>> Jesse: TWO YEARS INTO A
3-10-YEAR SENTENCE AND THE
DECISION BY THE PENNSYLVANIA
SUPREME COURT, GREG, I DID NOT
EXPECT THIS EITHER.
>> Greg: I DID, I'VE BEEN
WATCHING THIS CLOSELY.
I FEEL BAD FOR YOU, JESSIE,
WHILE HE WAS IMPRISONED YOU WERE
IN A SENSE AMERICA'S DAD.
>> Jesse: PEOPLE HAVE REFERRED
TO ME IS THAT.
>> Greg: I WAS HOPING YOU'D GO
TO HAROLD BECAUSE YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING'S EVERYTHING ABOUT
THIS BUT I WILL STILL HIS
TALKING POINTS, WE DON'T KNOW IF
THEY WOULD'VE BEEN ABLE TO
CONVICT HIM IF THEY HADN'T
CROSSED THE LINE SO HE HAS TO GO
FREE BECAUSE THEY SCREWED UP AND
THAT'S THE REASON, THE QUESTION
IS HOW COME NOBODY IN THE MEDIA
KNEW ABOUT THIS BUT THERE WAS
ONE PERSON WHO DID AND HIS NAME
RHYMES WITH GERALDO RIVERA WHO
CLAIMED THAT HE WAS THE GUY THAT
SAID THE COURT WAS TAINTED BY
PUBLIC OPINION AND SOCIAL
PRESSURE THAT PREJUDICED THE
EVIDENCE FOR IMPROPER WITNESSES
AND I THINK GERALDO'S WORD WAS
IT DOESN'T MATTER THAT HE'S A
BAD GUY, HE WAS RAILROADED.
IT'S AN INTERESTING THING
BECAUSE I...
I GET INVOLVED IN A CRIME GOING
TO TRY TO MAKE SURE IT'S AS
SCANDALOUS AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE I
WANT, I DON'T WANT THE COURT TO
FUNCTION OBJECTIVELY, THAT WAY I
CAN ALWAYS WIN THE APPEAL BUT IN
TERMS OF PUBLIC OPINION THIS IS
A REALLY GOOD POINT TO BE MADE
ESPECIALLY NOW, JUSTICE CAN BE
OVERWHELMED BY PUBLIC OPINION
WHICH IS NOT MAGNIFIED BY
SOCIAL MEDIA BECAUSE OF YOU
REMEMBER THE TIME THIS WAS GOING
ON, THERE WAS NO WAY HE COULD BE
INNOCENT BECAUSE ALL YOU HEARD
ALL THE TIME, YOU BELIEVE WHEN
YOU SEE THE STUFF ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, HOW COULD HE BE
INNOCENT?
THEN HE'S GOT HIS TEAM WORKING
AROUND THE CLOCK, HE SHOULD BUY
THEM ALL DRINKS BUT THEY
SHOULDN'T DRINK IT.
>> Jesse: AS GREG MENTIONED
THERE WAS A DEAL BY THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN PENNSYLVANIA,
HAROLD, HE DIDN'T THINK HE COULD
GET CONVICTION ON THE CRIMINAL
CRIMINAL CHARGE SO HE SAID WE
ARE NOT GOING TO PROSECUTE YOU
CRIMINALLY, WE WILL DO A CIVIL
CASE AND SO COSBY SAYS HEY, I'M
CLEAR WITH CRIMINAL CHARGES, I'M
GOING TO BE DEPOSED IN THIS
CIVIL CASE, ENDS UP SAYING YEAH,
I DID GIVE GIRLS QUAALUDES AND
YEARS LATER NEW TEAMS OF
PROSECUTORS CAME IN, DISREGARD
THIS AGREEMENT AND CHARGE THE
HECK OUT OF THE SKY, DO YOU
THINK THAT WAS PROSECUTORIAL?
>> Harold: I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jesse: OVERREACH?
>> Harold: I DON'T THINK
BILL COSBY WAS SAYING HE'S A
SAINT AND WHETHER WE AGREE WITH
THE OUTCOME OF THE TRIAL OR NOT,
WHAT IS CLEAR AS THE
SUPREME COURT SAYS YOU CAN'T
PROSECUTE A PERSON THIS WAY.
WE SHOULD ALL BE THANKFUL THAT
OUR SYSTEM IS PREDICATED AND
BUILT AROUND PROTECTING
INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS, THEY ARE
GOING TO BE OUTCOMES THAT WE
DON'T LIKE IN LEGAL CASES AND
THE MOST RECENT CASE LIKE OUT OF
A A LOT OF ATTENTION IS POLICE
OFFICER DEREK CHAUVIN IN
MINNESOTA, HE GOT A TRIAL IN THE
PROSECUTION HAD TO PUT ON THE
CASE, THAT'S OUR SYSTEM WORKS
AND IF THERE WAS PROSECUTORIAL
MISCONDUCT IN THIS CASE WITH
BILL COSBY, SHAME ON THOSE
PROSECUTORS BECAUSE IF HE DID
THE THINGS THAT THEY CLAIM HE
DID AND HE GETS OFF ON THIS
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T DO THEIR JOB
RIGHT, BE UPSET WITH THAT
BECAUSE THEY WERE THE ONES I
DIDN'T DO THEIR JOB CORRECTLY
AND DIDN'T FOLLOW THE LAW.
>> Jesse: KATIE, A JURY DID
STILL, PUTTING ASIDE THIS
AGREEMENT THAT WAS TRASH, THEY
LOOKED AT THE EVIDENCE AND FOUND
HIM GUILTY.
>> Katie: THERE'S THAT AND AS
YOU MENTIONED THE 2005 CIVIL
SUIT WHERE HE ADMITTED IN THE
DOCUMENTS WERE RELEASED THAT HE
DID IN FACT BUY DRUGS TO GIVE TO
WOMEN HE WANTED TO HAVE SEX
WITH.
THAT IS ON THE RECORD FROM
BILL COSBY.
IF YOU TRULY BELIEVE IN VICTIMS
RIGHTS AND YOU WANT JUSTICE FOR
VICTIMS YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE THAT
THE TECHNICALITIES MATTER, YOU
HAVE TO GET RID OF THE MOB, YOU
HAVE TO TAKE OUT THE EMOTIONAL
SIDE OF THIS BECAUSE IN THE END
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO
SUFFER ARE THE VICTIMS OF
SOMETHING THAT BILL COSBY
ADMITTED TO DOING AND THERE ARE
CASES LIKE THIS THAT PLAY OUT
ALL THE TIME AS A RESULT OF
EMOTION GETTING INTO THE
COURTROOM OR PROSECUTORS NOT
DOING THEIR JOB THE RIGHT WAY ON
THE VICTIMS WHO HAVE SPENT
DECADES OF THEIR LIFE TRYING TO
GET WHAT THEY DESERVE IN TERMS
OF SOME KIND OF JUSTICE FOR
CRIMES THAT WERE COMMITTED
AGAINST THEM THAT ALL GOES AWAY
IN THE BLINK OF AN EYE, LIKE
TODAY BECAUSE THE THINGS WEREN'T
DONE THE RIGHT WAY.
I BELIEVE THAT IS A GOOD THING
THAT THE SYSTEM HAS ALL OF THESE
PROTECTIONS BUILT IN FOR THE
ACCUSED AND IT'S UP TO AND HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
PROSECUTORS AND THE JUDGES END
OF A JURY TO STICK TO THE RULES
WE HAVE IN THE CONSTITUTION IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
VICTIMS SO THEY GET THE JUSTICE
THEY DESERVE.
>> Jesse: IS BECAUSE BASED ON
THE CLEAR?
DO YOU THINK PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
COME OUT OF THE WOODWORK YEARS,
YEARS, YEARS AFTER THE FACT TO
FILE ADDITIONAL CHARGES JUST TO
REALLY GET JUSTICE FOR ANY OF
THE WOMEN THAT ARE STILL OUT
THERE?
>> Dana: FOR THE PROSECUTOR
THAT SCREWED UP AND THEIR TEAM
AND I WOULD IMAGINE THEY ARE
GOING TO FEEL A DESIRE TO TRY TO
MAKE IT RIGHT AND THEY MIGHT NOT
BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
THEY SAID HE CAN'T BE PROSECUTED
AGAIN.
>> Jesse: IN PENNSYLVANIA.
THERE'S GOT TO BE OTHER WOMEN
OUT THERE.
>> Greg: FOR LOSING TIME?
IF THIS WAS AN INJUSTICE, HE
SHOULD BE THE ONE THAT IS SUING
FOR THE TWO YEARS OF HIS LOST
LIFE.
>> Dana: TO YOUR POINT, WHEN
YOU GET OLDER THAT TIME AS A
PERCENTAGE OF YOUR LIFE, I CAN'T
DO THE MATH, BUT IF YOU'RE IN
YOUR '80s AND YOU JUST SPENT
OVER TWO YEARS IN PRISON AND YOU
WERE THERE LOOK WRONGLY ON A
TECHNICALITY.
>> Jesse: THE TAXPAYERS OF
PENNSYLVANIA HAVE TO PAY A CLAIM
FOR BILL COSBY?
>> Katie: IF YOU LOOK AT IT
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF A WOMAN
WHO MAYBE HASN'T COME FORWARD
YET ARE GOING TO THE PROCESS OF
FILING OF CIVIL LAWSUIT OR
CRIMINAL CASE, IF YOU LOOK AT
THIS AND THE PROSECUTORS WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE PURSUING JUSTICE
ON YOUR BEHALF OR PROTECTING
YOU, SCREWED IT UP THIS WAY
AFTER YOU GET A CONVICTION FROM
A JURY, WHY WOULD YOU PUT
YOURSELF THROUGH IT IN A LOT OF
INSTANCES, RIGHT?
THEY PROBABLY FEEL